One last thing I'd like to talk about with br and
p, I'll show you right now. Let's let's make this all be
one line again, okay? So I update this and we have
one line. If we, we can put a br tag in the
middle of this. We don't actually have to have the line
breaks in our HTML. So when I click Update, we, we get
our, our line break no matter how the HTML is formatted. So,
we can format this however we want, put all of these spaces
in here. And when we update this, it'll always come out the
same. There's an example. All this white space turns into turns into one single
space. All of these new lines here, turn into one
single space. You know, this text space is really, you know, you get
the idea. Okay. Why do we have two different ways of making
new lines? Why do we have a br tag and a
p tag? The answer is because the br tag is what
we call inline, and the p tag, is what we call
block. Now, so what the br tag was actually doing was
just ending a line. So when we have some text and
we put a br in the middle of it, it just
basically says the line ends here and this guy wraps to
the next line. The p tag works differently. The p tag
actually makes an invisible box. So when we have HTML
looks like this, this creates an actual box. So instead
of just rendering text, blank line, what this is actually
rendering is something sort of like this. Here, we've got
two lines of text and there's actually this invisible box
around text. And that's what the p tag does, is
it makes this invisible box. And this invisible box can
actually have height, and it can have width, where inline elements
are just text. So the example over here would be
more like this. So it's just two lines of text and
there's really just a little new line here. There's nothing nothing
fancy going on. And the difference between inline and block elements
will come up a fair amount later in this course
and it's just it's important to know that there's a distinction
and they have kind of a different behavior. So far, all
of the elements we've learned other than p are inline elements.
So, inline elements are b, em, even img is
an inline element. And we saw how, before, our our little Hipmunk image appeared
right in the middle of the text. That's because it's inline. And
so far, the only block element we've learned is the p element.